hi guys welcome back again to the
channel today i'm going to reprogram my
key fob here on the right side because
yesterday night i did change the battery
and when i did try to use it uh it's not
working i was surprised like
i don't know why maybe it was
disconnected somehow and i did change
the battery
so now i'm going to try to reprogram it
but before i begin i'll give it a try
first to show you what i'm talking about
okay
so we'll give it a try on the remote
you see that red blink
okay it did not start
and
let's give it another try
it really doesn't work okay now let's
try the
this one
you can tell right away
now that you see that
this
remote is working and this one is not
so somehow when i did replace the
battery somehow maybe it was
disconnected and i'm gonna start to
reprogram it now
first step is you have to
press the engine start button twice
without uh pressing the brake or else
you're going to uh start the car so just
this
twice
one
two
and then after that you just wait for
the uh
screen to finish
and press okay and then
press the
remote lock five times one two three
four five
and then after that press the lock
at the driver's uh
door five times one two three four five
unlock the door manually
but before you go out press it once
to turn it off
then we're going to try
if it works
i think it works already see
see that one
i'll get the
other remote
the old one that works
okay
here
this is the one that we change uh this
is i mean this is the one that i did
reprogram
and this one
so you can see people works again
let's try this one this is no one let's
start it
[Music]
okay it is working
okay that is all for today i hope you
like it and if you do please don't
forget to comment like and subscribe
your support goes a long way and
see you on our next video
[Music]